I wanted to play bein John because I
don't know if I played being John before
played once before
okay and yeah let's play blindfold
actually let's play hoody moon assuming
bang John is still here
Oh being John in the chat okay I was not
ready okay at four what do you mode time
I will not be looking at the board or
the chapt towards going forward okay
thanks for thanks for subbing being part
of the cult b5 there we go okay so I can
see the keyboard just not the chess
board this is a Fromm's Kabat f3 g5 it's
got some g5 emotes in the chat d4 who
opponent may be prepared
d4 I think I can play d4 Knight g5 crazy
move g4 looks fun so free nights hmm so
my Queens attacked do I have a pawn on
f3 who was that that was someone maybe
that was vain John trying to distract me
so there's actually a few cam that moves
here I mean I could take on c7 I could
play f2 f2 is probably most logical
Queen h4 g3 yeah what son let's play up
to this is a desperado type move so I
was gonna lose up on anyway you have to
knock 27
it's a weird position g1 o g1 so ever
nights on g8 let's develop another piece
I lost a few ponds but now I have I have
the half of them G file virtue 8 coming
but yeah the mean target is the the like
king he for you for let's play a Queenie
five hitting the pawn Oh weights does
white have a pawn on d4 and white has a
pawning
oh no my queen Chuck my beautiful queen
that's okay whenever you're down a queen
you just have to go for Nate's
everything will be okay
actually I wanted to play Queenie five
earlier but the pollen he too would have
allowed for e3 and in this sort of
position now I'm sensing my pawns pain
20400 tog is back welcome back taki
meets GU maybe that will be will not be
Bo test gambit no blindfold protests
gambit part three but that was an
intentional Queen sacrifice okay thanks
for the game ain't John yeah I guess
I'll go on YouTube YouTube people thanks
for watching subscribe like share on
reddit goodbye